got me walk inside the sign between her
music hairspray live her new fragrance
sweet like candy and an upcoming tour
ariana grande is one busy gal it's a lot
but I'm very grateful to be doing what I
love
thankfully for fans Ari loves to share
snaps of her life like cuddling up with
boyfriend Mac Miller I think that me
being open with my fans and my
supporters is like a very important
thing because like it's like like you
know what I mean so like it's beautiful
the 23 year old tells et's Michelle
Turner
she's coming to terms with the world's
fascination with her personal life I am
the can't really go anywhere do anything
now without people seeing and knowing so
it's like I need to just kind of be okay
and be like hey that's okay if that's
what comes with me doing what I love and
people hearing my music and responding
then that's okay and I need to like you
know what life is good every day is good
I'm learning we're we're fine
Ariana and her rapper Bo are together on
his song my favorite part so we had to
know our ease favorites favorite part of
your tour life favorite part of my tour
life is seeing my fans on a daily basis
your favorite smell Ari and sweet like
candy what's your favorite way to spend
a day off making music I'm always in the
studio so it's like yeah I just went
last night I'm very excited I like MIDI
really close on last night what's your
favorite kind of date night going on
drives to like random like looking for
pokemons like going so cute movies like
making music you know what I mean what's
your favorite part about being in love
every day is like super exciting just
like waking up and be like hell yeah